imagine a world where farming is
automated precise and environmentally
friendly welcome to the era of modern
agricultural technology today we'll
unveil the top innovations that are
revolutionizing how we grow food ready
let's dive
in smart farming Solutions first on the
list smart farming Solutions with iot
sensors and AI technology farmers can
monitor soil Health moisture levels and
weather conditions in real time for
example this device right here can alert
Farmers if their crops need water or
nutrients saving resources and
increasing yield this isn't just
technology it's a smarter way to farm
[Music]
drones and
agriculture next up drones and
agriculture these flying marbles are
gamechangers for monitoring crops
spraying pesticides and even planting
seeds with their Precision drones reduce
waste and ensure every inch of the field
gets equal attention farmers in remote
areas are already using drones to save
time and labor and the best part they
can cover hectares in minutes
[Music]
robotic Machinery let's talk about
robotic Machinery gone are the days of
backbreaking manual labor these robots
can plant Harvest and sort crops faster
than ever before take a look at this
harvesting robot it uses AI to identify
ripe fruits picking them gently without
damaging the plant
from lettuce to strawberries robots are
ensuring quality and consistency in
farming like never
[Music]
before sustainable Tech and solar
powerered machines sustainability is at
the heart of modern agricultural
technology machines powered by solar
energy and systems like drip irrigation
are helping reduce carbon Footprints
these Technologies ensure farmers can
grow more food with less water making
farming eco-friendly and costeffective
for instance this solar powered tractor
runs all day without a drop of fuel
imagine the savings for farmers and the
[Music]
environment the these are just a few
examples of how modern agricultural
technology is transforming farming from
Smart sensors to robotic Harvesters the
future of Agriculture is here and it's
exciting which technology amazed you the
most let us know in the comments below
and don't forget to like share and
subscribe for more Tech driven farming
insights thank you for your watching and
see you in the next video
[Music]